That's actually why people get married,
you know,
just so you know,
because this is built into marital vows,
I'm not leaving ever no matter what.
It's like,
okay,
well that definitely puts a boundary
around our arguments,
right?
Because I can't say every time you
manifest one of your flaws,
which you're likely to do just as often
as me.
Well enough for this.
It's like,
that's horrible,
man.
If your whole life is while every time
you get out of line,
I'm out of here.
It's like,
how the hell are you?
First of all,
you're not going to admit to ever doing
anything wrong.
Second,
you're going to be on your.
You're like,
ah,
like a scared cat.
The entire relationship because well,
who knows?
It could just come to an end at any
moment.
It's like,
you know,
people say,
well,
if you're.
If the possibility of divorce is open,
it makes you free.
It's like,
yeah,
that's what you want.
Do you want to be free?
A really,
really,
so you can't predict anything.
That's what you're after.
It's a vow and it says,
look,
I know that you're trouble me too,
so we won't leave no matter what
happens.
Well,
that's a hell of a vowel,
but that's why it's about right.
That's why you take it in front of a
bunch of people.
That's why it's supposed to be a sacred
act.
It's like,
what's the alternative?
What's the alternative?
Everything is mutable and changeable at
any moment.
Well,
go ahead.
You liver,
your liver,
your life like that,
and see what you're like when you're 50
Jesus.
It's dismal.
Two or three divorces.
Your family's fragmented.
You've got no continuity of narrative.
It's not.
It's not good for the kids,
not by any stretch of the imagination,
and so it's a form of voluntary
enslavement I suppose,
but it's also equivalent to the adoption
of a responsibility and there's more to
it than that.
If you can't run away,
then you can solve your problems because
it might be,
okay,
well I'm stuck with you.
So how about we fix things
because the alternative is we're going
to be in a boxing match for the next 40
years.
That's the alternative.
So.
And you think you're going to fix
problems without something like that
hanging over your head.
There isn't a chance.
You'll just avoid them because that's
what people do.
It's really hard to,
to solve problems,
especially in relationship.
We're having a fight and I find out that
it's because you're.
You were abused by your uncle when you
were five or some God damn thing.
You know,
it's like,
it's very frequent that that sort of
thing happens.
You,
there's the partner,
your partner is manifesting some weird
anomalous behavior.
You just can't make heads or tails of
it.
That doesn't seem related to what you're
doing at all.
They don't want to talk about it.
And so as soon as you bring it up,
they get mad and then you bring it up
again.
They even get mad or,
and they tell you that you're not going
to talk about that or they're going to
leave.
And so maybe you really,
really persistent because you're kind of
a son of a bitch and then they break
down and cry,
you know?
And then they have this horrible memory
that comes flooding forward.
That's completely.
You don't know what to do with it,
and then you have to sort it out.
It's like you think you're going to do
that unless there's a good reason.
You have to know we better start this
out and we're going to be carrying it
around for the next 40 years.
That may be is enough motivation,
so you'll actually try hard to solve a
problem.
It's a lot easier to say,
well,
sorry,
we're not going there,
but then good,
and you'll have it every day,
every day,
every God damn day for the rest of your
life.